sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren wir alle
wünschen uns eine welt frei von gewalt
von terror und von missbrauch wünschen
uns eine welt ohne körperliche und
seelische misshandlungen die auf die
schwächsten der schwachen treffen aber
wir wissen auch meine damen und herren
das absolute prävention und absolute
sicherheit
es sind unsere offenen gesellschaft
nicht geben kann
und ich liebe wird eine offene
gesellschaft ist leider immer auch
verwundbar
das haben wir schmerzlich erlebt im
dezember 2016 beim furchtbaren
islamistischen terroranschlag hier in
berlin auf dem breitscheidplatz und das
wussten wir leider auch erleben vor
einigen tagen jüngst wieder beim
rechtsextremen terroranschlag am 19
oktober in halle
was mich stört meine damen und herren
ist das nach gewalttaten und nach
solchen anschlägen in der öffentlichen
berichterstattung und alt zu vielen
medien auch in unserem land sehr sehr
viel über die täter berichtet wird aber
viel zu wenig über die opfer dieser
gewollt hat die opfer die leidtragenden
meine damen und herren
die müssen im mittelpunkt stehen und mit
diesem gesetzentwurf mit dem neuen
sozialen entschädigungsrecht stellen wir
die interessen der opfer von gewalttaten
und von kriminalität in den mittelpunkt
bislang war das entschädigungsrecht auch
die opfer der beiden weltkriege
konzentriert und auf deren situation
eingerichtet das war in den 50er jahren
einen kriegsfolgen entschädigungsgesetz
was dem ganzen zu grunde lag das ist
heute längst nicht mehr unsere
lebenswirklichkeit
wir haben eine andere lebenswirklichkeit
und genau auf diese soziale
lebenswirklichkeit richtet sich das neue
entschädigungsgesetz aus wir fassen
meine damen und herren mit diesen
regelungen die wir zusammen fassen im
übrigen schaffen wir ein neues
sozialgesetzbuch gleichzeitig ist mir
aber wichtig an dieser stelle deutlich
zu machen das ist den intensiven
gesprächen auch mit vielen opfer
verbänden ein thema gewesen dass mit dem
neuen sozialen entschädigungsrecht
niemand der
dem bisherigen recht leistung bezieht
schlechter gestellt wird ist eine klare
botschaft auch des vertrauensschutzes
was dieses soziale entschädigungsrecht
allerdings leistet ist dass wir mehr
menschen erreichen und dass es mehr und
bessere leistungen gibt das ist eine
wichtige nachricht meine damen und
herren für menschen die schlimmes erlebt
haben
für uns ist wichtig dass die opfer von
gewalttaten den weg zurückfinden ins
arbeitsleben in einen geregelten alltag
und in die vollständige soziale teilhabe
am gesellschaftlichen leben
das ist für viele betroffene menschen
die opfer von gewalttaten geworden sind
kein einfacher weg es ist ein harter weg
aber wir sagen als staat und
gesellschaft das darf kein einsamer weg
sein wir wollen den menschen auf diesem
weg effektiv helfen und deshalb bauen
sie ein hilfesystem auf das mitfühlen
und respektvoll mit den opfern umgeht
das aber auch effektiv und zielgenau
wirken soll
deshalb ist mir sehr wichtig dass wir
mit diesem gesetz beispielsweise die
wertvolle arbeit von trauma ambulanzen
stärken ich habe mir das in berlin hier
angeguckt was da geleistet wird wir
können vielen opfern von gewalttaten
helfen dem wir frühzeitig mit trauma
ambulanzen helfen auch die seelischen
den psychischen folgen bewältigen zu
können die aus gewalttaten resultieren
erhalten opfer von gewalttaten von
psychischer erfolge und körperlicher
hilfe tatsächlich frühzeitig hilfe
beratung und betreuung
mit diesem gesetz werden die leistungen
der trauma ambulanzen flächendeckend
zugänglich gemacht und es wird ergänzt
durch ein individuelles fallmanagement
der präsidentin frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren
mir ist wichtig dass wir mit diesem
gesetz auch die opfer von sexueller
gewalt in den blick nehmen
das sind menschen und wir haben das den
letzten jahrzehnten in denen mehr
menschen sich geöffnet haben und wir
auch mehr öffentliche berichterstattung
über dieses thema haben
das sind menschen die oft ein leben lang
mit seelischen und teilweise auch mit
körperlichen schäden zu kämpfen haben
und viele dieser opfer können sich erst
viele jahre später öffnen
und offen auch über das reden was ihnen
passiert ist bisher nach geltendem recht
war es für diese frauen und männer
besonders schwierig nachzuweisen dass
der missbrauch ursache für manchmal dann
auch spätere und aktuelle psychische
erkrankung ist diese beweisführung wird
künftig mit dem sozialen
entschädigungsrecht wesentlichen
einfacher und das meine damen und herren
ist eine frage von würde und
gerechtigkeit dass wir menschen die
schweren missbrauch erlebt haben auch
später helfen können und sie nicht
mühsam eine beweiskette nachweisen
müssen an dieser stelle die sie dann
manchmal ein zweites mal traumatisiert
ich finde das einen wesentlichen schritt
und es geht uns in diesem gesetz
beispielsweise auch um die frauen und
männer die opfer von schweren stocking
geworden sind das ist ja vor einiger
zeit noch nicht so im öffentlichen
bewusstsein gewesen wir haben langsam
erst schritt für schritt dafür gesorgt
dass zum beispiel ein strafgesetzbuches
entsprechende verschaffen eine regelung
gegeben hat aber schwere stalking hat
für die betroffenen menschen hat für die
opfer auch oft erhebliche psychische
folgen und deshalb haben sie mit diesem
gesetzentwurf die möglichkeit erstmals
auch auf gesetzliche
entschädigungsanspruch und was man nicht
vergessen darf was uns vor allen dingen
aus dem bericht des opfer beauftragten
kurt beck des früheren opfer
beauftragten nach dem furchtbaren
terroranschlag am breitscheidplatz
beschäftigt hat die situation von
menschen die zwar nicht selbst
attackiert wurden aber die miterleben
mussten wie andere attackiert oder gar
umgebracht wurden die zeugen von
gewalttaten und von kriminalität und von
terroranschlägen sind oft auch menschen
die opfer geworden sind weil sie schwer
traumatisiert wurden nach dem äußeren
anschein unversehrt aber seelisch oft
schwer verletzt auch sie werden
zukünftig einen anspruch auf leistungen
haben uns zwar unabhängig von der
bisherigen restriktionen ihrer
persönlichen vorgeschichte als
emotionaler nähe zu den opfern wie eben
körperlich attackiert wurden auch das
meine damen und herren eine wesentliche
konsequenz die menschen
auch eine lehre aus dem breitscheidplatz
ist übrigens meine damen und herren dass
künftig nicht mehr die frage der
staatsangehörigkeit darüber entscheidet
welche leistungen menschen bekommen alle
die hier in deutschland opfer von
gewalttaten werden werden gleich
behandelt
wir hatten ganz schwierige diskussionen
beispielsweise weil auf dem
breitscheidplatz menschen zb mit
israelischer nationalität opfer geworden
sind wie es denn jetzt um ihre
entschädigungsrecht und das der
angehörigen bestellt ist das ist meine
damen und herren etwas was mir wichtig
ist unsere offene gesellschaft versucht
alles zu tun um mit den mitteln des
rechtsstaates der prävention der polizei
der justiz behörden wo immer es geht
kriminalität und gewalt zu verhindern
bevor sie entsteht das ist die
staatliche schutz verantwortung unseres
gemeinwesens aber in einer offenen
gesellschaft ist das nicht immer möglich
und wenn wir da die staatliche
schutzverantwortung eben nicht ausgeübt
wurde dann muss wesentlichen die soziale
schutzverantwortung in der hilfe von
opfer und zwar unabhängig von ihrer
nationalität auf deutschen boden gewährt
werden meine damen und herren
wer opfer einer gewalttat wird
er hat unsere solidarität unser vollstes
mitgefühl verdient
wir können erlittenes leid meine damen
und herren nicht rückgängig machen aber
es ist unsere verantwortung die
betroffenen auf ihrem schwierigen weg zu
begleiten
es geht um licht es geht um licht der
hoffnung da wo dunkel ist und ich bitte
sie ganz herzlich
in der anstehenden parlamentarischen
beratung für dieses wesentliche neue
recht für dieses neue soziale gesetz
punkte sozialen entschädigungsrecht um
ihre unterstützung herzlichen dank für
die vielen wertes heil der
bundesminister für arbeit und soziales
und meine damen und herren sie sehen
schon wir warten während wir hier auch
im bundestag zu hören auf eine
pressekonferenz von angela merkel denn
auf dem gipfel der eu staats und
regierungschefs gab es ja einen großen
durchbruch dass sich die eu staaten und
großbritannien auf einem brett deal
geeinigt haben sobald also die
pressekonferenz von angela merkel
beginnt werden wir darüber schalten aber
erstmal bleiben wir noch im bundestag
dort spricht jetzt martin sichert von
der s d fraktion und zu schützen ist
verpflichtung aller staatlichen gewalt
der staat hat also in aller erster
stelle dafür zu sorgen dass den menschen
die würde nicht genommen wird seine
vordringlichste aufgabe ist menschen zu
schützen und ursachen zu bekämpfen die
menschen die würde nehmen die würde des
menschen ist unantastbar so steht es im
grundgesetz die würde es nicht mit geld
kompensierbar und zur würde des menschen
gehört auch dass jeder nach seinem
freien willen entscheiden darf was sie
hier bei der impf gesetzgebung machen
ist das gegenteil davon
sie wollen auf der einen seite eine
impfpflicht für masern einführen obwohl
in vielen europäischen ländern mit
impfpflicht deutlich mehr menschen an
masern erkranken als in deutschland und
auf der anderen seite wollen sie dann
die entschädigung für leute verbessern
die von der impfung schäden davontragen
das ist das was wir von der regierung
immer wieder sehen meine setzt
freiwilligkeit durch zwang und für die
auftretenden schäden wird dann großzügig
das hart verdiente geld der steuerzahler
verteilt
lassen sie uns doch mal den geist des
grundgesetzes den geist der würde des
menschen und der freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung leben lassen
wir jeden frei entscheiden ob er geimpft
werden möchte oder nicht das wäre ein
starkes zeichen dass der staat die würde
und eigenverantwortung der bürger
respektiert aber zur würde des menschen
gehört nicht nur die freie entscheidung
sondern auch die körperliche und
psychische und physische unversehrtheit
und auch hier ergreifen sie keine
maßnahmen zum schutz der bürger sondern
sie kennen nur den griff
in den geldbeutel der steuerzahler der
defa berichtet aktuell dass in
deutschland über 70.000 frauen genital
verstümmelt sind und mehr als 17.000 600
mädchen gefährdet sind das gleiche
schicksal zu erleiden
seit jahren steigen die zahlen der
genitalverstümmelung durch die
zuwanderung aus archaischen
kulturkreisen warum schützen sie denn
diese frau nicht und was ist denn mit
der würde von hunderttausenden jungen
frauen in deutschland die nicht frei
sind in der wahl ihres ehepartners weil
sie aus kulturen kommen in denen sie
zwangsverheiratet werden oder mit dem
tod bedroht werden wenn sie jemanden aus
einer anderen kultur heiraten
das sind alles opfer von sexueller
gewalt das sind alles opfer von
sexueller gewalt in deutschland warum
treten sie in ein artikel eins mit füßen
wenn es um die würde dieser mädchen und
dieser jungen frauen in deutschland geht
nach zwei jahren nach zwei jahren
bundestag weiß nicht warum sie sich hier
so aufregend warum sie diese mädchen und
frauen nicht schützen
sie müssten nämlich zu geben dass
multikulti gescheitert ist denn der
einzige weg diese frauen und mädchen zu
schützen ist es dass eine
gleichberechtigte freiheitliche
leitkultur in unserem land etabliert
wird und sich jeder zugereisten hier
nicht aufhören kann wie im heimatland
aber statt dass sie verantwortung
übernehmen machen sie alles noch
schlimmer
sie schaffen einen weiteren anreiz die
würde dieser frauen mit füßen zu treten
indem sie mit ihren hier vorliegenden
gesetzesentwurf die genitalverstümmelung
mit einem finanziellen anreiz von 400
euro monatlich versehen
hören sie auf ihre fehler mit dem griff
zum scheckbuch zu versuchen zu
vertuschen sondern handeln sie endlich
um die würde der schwächsten in dieser
gesellschaft zu schützen
sie schreiben in ihrem gesetzesentwurf
der minister hat ja auch angesprochen
dass das gesetz eine folgerung aus den
auswirkungen des verheerenden
terroranschlag vom weiter platz ist wir
sehen sie aber nicht im nahen osten wo
man mit blutgeld selbstmorde söhnen kann
im nachhinein den opfer angehörigen der
opfer geld und unterstützung zukommen zu
lassen
das mag kurzfristig manche besänftigen
macht die taten aber nicht ungeschehen
und es löst auch keine probleme
wir brauchen hier kein blut geld gesetzt
sondern eine bekämpfung von ursachen
dieser gesetze sind noch jaja regen sie
sich alle nur auf dieser gesetzentwurf
zeigt ihre hilflosigkeit und es
letztlich nichts anderes als die
bankrotterklärung ihrer politik der
inneren sicherheit um die ursachen des
terrors zu bekämpfen feuchten wir einen
klaren kampf gegen extremismus jeder art
aber darin versagen sie kläglich
spd grüne und linke suchen den
schulterschluss mit rechtsextremisten
solange die rechtsextremisten nicht
deutsche sondern türken sind am tag der
deutschen einheit rahn vertreter ihrer
drei parteien bei einer veranstaltung
die nicht nur von einer sondern gleich
von vier nationalistisch islamistisch
gesinnten organisationen darunter der
bekanntesten rechtsextremen türkischen
gruppe den grauen wölfen ausgerichtet
wurde sie oft ihren nicht nur
linksextremisten sondern auch
rechtsextremisten und islamisten und
dann bezeichnen sie sich immer wieder
als demokratischen fraktionen was für
einen hohen was für ein witz
ein abgeordneter der linken harald
weinberg hat den anschlag von ansbach
mit 15 verletzten und einem toten mit
ermöglicht indem man sich im vorfeld
tatkräftig dafür einsetzte dass der
attentäter im land bleiben darf die
bundesregierung hier sorgt für ein klima
des terrors zwischen kurden und türken
auf deutschen straßen in dem sie sich
gegen ein waffenembargo einsetzt und
damit eindeutig auf die seite des
islamisten erdogan schlägt in die tib
moscheen in deutschland predigt man für
einen sieg des bündnisses aus türkische
armee und islamisten des und die
bundesregierung schaut tatenlos zu
74 genozide gab es an den je 7 74
völkermorde ähnlich wie die juden eine
quer durch die geschichte immer wieder
massakrierte bevölkerungsgruppe wissen
sie wer die einzigen waren die versucht
haben krieges ihnen beim letzten
völkermord vor den islamisten zu
schützen wissen sie wer es war
das waren die von erdogan bekämpften
wurden von ihr budget und pkk und sie
von der bundesregierung stehen auf der
seite der islamisten erdogans und des
islamischen staats sie sind die
unterstützer von völkermörder schlimmer
kann man die deutsche geschichte kaum
mit füßen treten
wissen sie was linksextremisten
rechtsextremisten islamisten und die
bundesregierung gemeinsam haben die
befeuerung des antisemitismus und des
kampfes gegen israel lehnen wir doch mal
klartext wenn sie antisemitismus nicht
propaganda ausschlachten können stören
sie nicht doch überhaupt nicht daran
ganz im gegenteil bei den vereinten
nationen stimmen sie ständig der
verurteilung israels zu und befeuern so
auch den antisemitismus in deutschland
vorgestern erst konnten wir wieder sehen
dass die bundesregierung im gegensatz zu
vielen anderen staaten nicht mehr den
anlage ist jerusalem als hauptstadt
israels anzuerkennen
stattdessen paktieren sie ständig mit
arabischen staaten bei der un gegen
israel staaten die am liebsten heute
statt morgen einen erneuten holocaust an
den juden vollbringen und israel
auslöschen würden
statt ihre politik zu ändern legen sie
hier eine network vor den opfern von
gewalttaten die durch ihre politik
verursacht werden schneller geld
zukommen zu lassen was deutschland aber
wirklich brauchen würde
ist ein wechsel
in der politik jede moschee in der für
einen sieg erdogans gebetet wurde die
gehört geschlossen und jedem der da
gebetet hat ein freiflug seien in die
türkei geschenkt und wir müssen uns klar
gegen den antisemitismus und den kampf
gegen israel stehen denn das ist die
klammer die alle extremisten vereint und
dass sie von der linken hier so
rumschreien deswegen das zeigt dass das
wirklich die vereine klammer für alle
extremisten ist lassen sie uns gemeinsam
uns zu israel bekennen
der einzige funktionierende demokratie
im nahen osten lassen sie uns dieses
bekenntnis zu israel ablegen um jedem
rechtsextremisten jedem islamisten und
jedem linksextremisten die zornesröte
ins gesicht zu treiben und klar zu
machen nie nie wieder antisemitismus
keinen rechtsextremismus keine
linksextremisten nicht an den islamismus
auf deutschem boden
das ist die politik im sinne der opfer
[Applaus]
die redefreiheit in unserem haus ist
eine großartige freiheit und
errungenschaft und von aller
allergrößter bedeutung in einer
demokratie aber diese rede
die hat in hohem maße die grenzen des
politischen anstands überschritten
und ein gesetz das jetzt vorgelegte und
ist über den sich vortrefflich der
politische streit anbietet wie man es am
besten gestalten kann
als blutgeld gesetz zu beschreiben ist
in hohem maße in hohem maße zu rügen
deswegen bekommt jetzt hubertus heil das
wort zu einer kurzintervention frau
präsidentin sehr geehrter herr kollege
sehr geehrter herr kollege ich stelle
fest dass sie in bettes heirat das wort
zu einer kurzintervention sehr geehrter
kollege stelle fest dass sie zum
gesetzentwurf an sich in dem es ja um
die frage geht wie wir opfern von
gewalttaten besser helfen nichts gesagt
haben dass sie meiner rede
offensichtlich auch nicht zugehört haben
der ich deutlich gemacht habe das ist
eine staatliche verpflichtung das alles
zu tun wo immer es geht menschen vor
gewalt und kriminalität zu schützen
aber ich habe auch darauf hingewiesen
dass in einer offenen gesellschaft in
einer nicht totalitären gesellschaft es
keine absolute sicherheit gibt und wenn
sie mal in israel waren ich weiß nicht
ob sie sie eben leben in israel warnen
und mit dort mit staatlichen stellen
reden
die einen hohen sicherheitsapparat haben
wir eine demokratie sind die versuchen
sich gegen gewalt und terror auch zu
wehren aber die eben auch ein soziales
entschädigungsrecht entwickeln mussten
weil menschen auch in dieser
gesellschaft opfer von anschlägen
geworden sind dann wissen sie wie
wichtig das ist aber eines will ich ihn
auch ins stammbuch schreiben sie haben
heute ja nichts gesagt und ihre
beispiele sind ja immer sehr einschlägig
über die opfer zb von
rechtsextremistischen terror von frauen
die von skinheads geschlagen wurden die
ähnliches sondern sie haben versucht
diese debatte zu missbrauchen für ihre
agitation und da kann ich ihnen nur eins
sagen einem zitat von kurt schumacher
aus dem jahren unter 32 in diesem haus
wissen sie wie ein nationalismus für
ihre reden genannt hat die mobilisierung
des menschlichen schweine uns und ich
finde das haben sie mit dem begriff
blutgeld zum ausdruck gebracht sie
sollten sich schämen für diese rede
sie sollten sich schämen sollten sich
schämen dafür dass sie kein wort gesagt
haben des mitgefühls mit menschen die
opfer sind sie haben nichts gesagt wie
man opfern hilft sondern sie haben die
opfer von gewalttaten für ihre
nationalistische hetze in diesem haus
missbraucht und dafür sollten sich
schämen und entschuldigen mein herr
das wollte ich ihnen sagen
fraktionsübergreifender beifall für
bundesminister hubertus heil day hier
aus den reihen der spd fraktion sprechen
muss um einen kurzintervention zu machen
nun die antwort aus der ard würde mich
freuen wenn sie aufstehen würden mir
zuzuhören zehnter winzerin kann er
entscheiden ob er stehen bleibt oder
nicht tut dann haben wir aber
tatsächlich mir auch nicht richtig
zugehört denn ich habe diverse
problembereiche angesprochen wo sie neue
problemfälle schaffen beispielsweise bei
den genitalen verstümmelten frauen bei
den mädchen die von genitalverstümmelung
bedroht sind in deutschland es ist
unsere vordringlichste aufgabe hier
nicht mit dem geldbeutel rumzulaufen und
leuten geld zu geben die opfer geworden
sind natürlich gehört dass auf der
staatlichen aufgabe die vordringlichste
aufgabe des staates ist dafür zu sorgen
dass menschen überhaupt nicht erst opfer
werden und da muss angegangen werden das
heißt wir müssen uns klar positionieren
wir müssen klar einschreiten gegen
parallelgesellschaften in denen frauen
zwangsverheiratet vergewaltigt und
geschlagen werden wir müssen uns klar
positionieren denn das sind
hunderttausende fälle in diesem land von
sexualisierter gewalt wir müssen uns
klarmachen gegen zehntausende fälle von
genitalverstümmelung und wir müssen uns
auch klar machen gegen den terror der
europa seit etlichen jahren jetzt
erfasst hat und die ursachen dieses
terrors bekämpfen und wenn wir sehen
dass man aus dem breitscheidplatz lernt
dass man den opfern schnellere
leistungen zur verfügung stellen muss
dann ist das eine konsequenz die
sinnvollere konsequenz wäre aber zu
sagen wir wollen dafür sorgen dass
ist nicht mehr möglich ist wie anis
ambri als jemand der ausreisepflichtig
ist monatelang in deutschland zu bleiben
dass es nicht möglich ist mit mehreren
identitäten den also um zu verschleiern
das wäre eine wirklich sinnvolle politik
dem sinne auf arbeit
[Applaus]